[Music]
cattle on the tampa bay's got missing
just above the cold peninsula
sorry we've got a shootout under the ice
I told six feet you want a hunter-killer
we've been ordered across waters that no
American sub has ever crossed before
to merge the ship
we are witnessing the most aggressive
military buildup in Russian history
we've been keeping tabs on Russian
president in his defense minister Doron
oh my god
it's a cool we're dealing with a single
Road Minister what if we could free
presidents the car we rescue the Russian
president listen ears around captain
waiting orders we're going in put four
of our boys and get one Russian
president we need a local navigator I
wish my men where's my ship because it
was the right thing to do this is about
our future if we don't pull this off
it's gonna be World War 3 you will be
court-martialed that is my job to keep
you alive long enough so you can testify
feels in the water [ __ ] put it solution
ready weapon ready 5 seconds sir
fire
did we just start a war you know put
myself in the one
now stations
that's a warship Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]